[Music]
makes Louise and Alex it's the first
time they've seen this HMOs are recently
secured
Tommy said I would work to hug her when
I say that house was it better than you
thought and I had high expectations I'd
done a visual tour
yeah the description and she was pretty
spot-on actually yeah right
the better you got ya cracking a
brilliant some high five one good job
guy that was an amazing house how much
how much went are we gonna be getting
with that guys 1600 1600 and it's
absolutely yes fire doors included
furnishings included flat upstairs its
own self-contained flat didn't how much
did you pay for it 112 112 investment on
that direction to say we wanted an HMO I
was considering sleepless nights
happening all sorts of hassles with
builders and that's so good you've been
plugged into the system now you part of
the family and also the great thing
about the house is the fact that it's
already tenant it
so we already agreed to rent no but
we're not guessing or estimating the
prices the tenants are actually paying
[Music]
yeah boiler yeah
I wouldn't let you be excited when I you
got to play it cool and then you can be
excited in the car otherwise he already
said he was resentful selling it'll be
salt in the wound if we won yeah this is
incredible Wow yeah we don't make him
feel bad about that what we can do is
swiftly and quickly absolutely so then
we can stop absolutely you got it right
let's go and see the mortgage broker
that's going I think within four weeks
of seeing you we've bought the property
with you
got a limited company started up and
just opened a new limited completely
bank account this property I've seen
today for the first time and it goes
above and beyond what we could have
expected and easier than any way we
could have expected to get an HMO
because we talked about it but unless
you actually take some action but I
think because of your motivation and
enthusiasm within your team yeah I'm
having the team like meeting Andrew
today yeah yeah you know even though
wearing of him
and this is all any different parts of
the country from where we live
yeah that's pride I guess that's the
idea isn't it just hear people say it
[Music]
overt oh my
yes yeah yeah she did
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
why I'm Samuel is and the reason we get
professional football players are bank
managers and seasoned investors coming
to us to solve properties for them is
for two reasons number one
because we have 80 of Deal sources you
spend 40 hours a week finding good
properties and we really know what we're
looking forward been doing this eight
years and for reason number two is that
we've got a fantastic reputation because
we always under-promise and over-deliver
in everything we do so if you're looking
to find good properties whether they be
HMOs lease option agreements or below
market value property then go to
www.prophecyinthenews.com at you game
and sign up for our early bird list and
I look forward to seeing you on the
other side